[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
مرت ثعلب
وبذيله 70 لفه قال اليوم ساضع احدا اضحك
اضحك بالتعب
[موسيقى]
عند البركه ارنب يصطاد الاسماك ويجذب قال
ساسرق منه السمكه وساخذ ذيلي وساهرب
وتقسمت منه وفرق وعلى بيت جده مر
[موسيقى]
شاهد بسكوتا مخبوزا ساخن وعليه السكر قال
الماكر ما اشهى بطني الجائع ويتمناه سبب
الطبقه اليه بسرعه وبلمح البصر
فاتبتعدوا المسكر يلتفت يمينه ويسار
يفحصين
ياكلهم
[موسيقى]
صادف ايضا بالطرقات كتكوته تلاقم الصاصه
اتباع الماكر بالذات واستهزا
يسخر طول الدرب ليس هنالك شيء صعب
لمح بكوخ عصير قال الماكر وقت الشرب رفع
الكوب لكي يشربه امسكه بالحال الكلب قال
له اهلا يا ما تفعله
رد بخوف اني اسف اعترف امامك بالذنب اعطهم
كل الابرار خذها واتركني اهرب